you
[Music]
chef Tony Montano has been satisfying
Chicago's taste for fine Italian food
for more than three decades he was a
music major in college and only started
working in restaurants as a part-time
job the cooking soon became his passion
he started his career in Wisconsin but
found his way to the Windy City and
later spent a year working in top
restaurants throughout Italy bringing
their secrets home to his restaurant
spiaggia a must visit venue on Chicago's
dining scene chef Tony Montano what
welcome to the dish thanks for being
here thank you for the invitation I'm so
excited
I mean besides this our son lives here
in New York so we get to have dinner
with him after this okay thank tell us
what's on this table so if we could
start way on the end over there that's a
drink with like my favorite alcoholic
tequila and Aperol and a little Prosecco
so it's almost like a Mexican Italian
the ground Negroni
and then the next serving for a Saturday
morning the shrimp dish is a dish that
we do at the US Open every year and this
flaming ouzo shrimp is so powerful when
you cook it and you pour the mousse on
light on fire which we won't do here
darn it permeates the entire Arthur Ashe
Stadium I think I may be pushing it but
that's good tennis and then of course
from Chicago we have a big steak and in
the Tuscan tradition of bistecca alla
Fiorentina
and then over here is a ravioli which is
a type pasta that is a sheet then we
wrap around cheese and bake it and now
we have spring vegetables because it's
spring course and then this is my
childhood on the very end this is a what
my grandmother from Calabria used to
call us Khalidi and it's coated in honey
and fried and it's just like oh my god
alight yeah yeah let's talk about your
childhood you are you were gonna be a
musician
it was Rhambo and I hear ya trombones so
it's interesting we did form a band a
brass band yeah like you know was the
days of Chicago and Earth Wind & Fire
tower of power and the other bands that
really influenced us and then years
later when I was on Top Chef Masters
with Jonathan Waxman another trombone
player so I like both chefs and actually
grew up in the Bay Area so he knew you
know
yeah we could have done it yeah what I
gather you're first a meeting this is
the one how did you make that transition
though from the trombone to the kitchen
it was like cold turkey it's like guys
they have been married for 32 years and
my wife Cathy has never seen me play the
trombone ever so okay you were done when
you were done I was done why I wanted to
cook I always wanted to cook I mean if
food was a big part of growing up
everything that we did but that we're
love of food I mean you talk about your
Italian grandmother she must have
imparted a lot of kind of wisdom and
enthusiasm for this kind of food
totally like every holiday we were at
their house they also had the montemagno
food shop which was part of the
italian-american community in Kenosha
Wisconsin so it was all about food he
had it my grandfather had a great guard
and she was a great cook so it's like
yeah I'd like I'd like to continue
eating this well okay well you know we
mentioned that once you get your first
job in Chicago there was time they
actually sent you to Italy for a year
right yes what was that like to be well
I mean you know this is back in the
early 80s no you know no internet like
if you were going someplace you had a
map all right I remember it was a lot
different but really what they told us
there when we were working those
restaurants are like wow you guys are
like the first Americans that have come
here to learn a lot of times American
restaurant tours will call Italy and say
hey I need an Italian chef but you're
like doing it really different so they
they really like that and they really
want to make sure we learn so they took
a lot of attention when you clearly
learned and now you're in Chicago which
is one of the great restaurant cities in
America these days yeah we love and
spiaggia it's got a great location right
on Oak in Michigan and across from the
beach and we have fine dining admission
star we have a cafe and we have great
spots for private dining both in the
restaurant and in our private event
space dominating this mean more than 30
years believe it or not chef as I asked
you to sign this dish as a system on
this program I'll ask you the question
we always ask which is if you could
share this bounty with any figure past
or present who would it be
so my namesake so my father had an older
brother named Tony montemagno who
actually was lost at Iwo Jima
world war two but the thing was he was
an incredible musician I think like
maybe I may be where you got yeah I
never met to meet Yemen cook for him to
tonymont to Ana's one table I loved it
chef Tony Montano great to see you thank
you and congrats on all the success
thank you for more on chef Tony Montano
and the dish head to our website at CBS
this morning calm